[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum great guest today yeah
I say that every time but I I really
enjoy all the interviews I'm very
attentive I listen I like putting on
these headphones and getting caught up
in someone else's world and also
selfishly seeing if their their world
their ideas ideologies their uh
principles there uh
the things they do to make themselves
feel better
I like to steal from them
yeah yeah D Wallace uh you know are from
uh many things you've seen her in many
things the mom and E.T and Cujo and
she's worked a ton but
boy this could be one of the most
emotional episodes the most Raw
real
um she breaks down talking about her
ex-husband who passed away unexpectedly
many years ago and it's like it happened
yesterday when she when she thinks about
it
and uh
she helps people
you can talk to her for advice for um
therapy I guess you'll listen to the
podcast and you'll you'll you'll you'll
learn a lot and you'll decide if you
want to do that which I would recommend
because she's
amazing uh
the handles to listen to the podcast as
you know it really helps if you listen
and you follow us and you write a review
all that stuff is Monumental for the
podcast Ryan uh inside of you Paula on
Twitter outside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook yeah that is true
and uh if you want to join patreon to uh
help the podcast more the folks over at
patreon are really helping patreon.com
inside of you become a member there's so
many perks you get shout outs at the end
of every episode and tons of great stuff
and I'm on the Cameo uh you know what
else the band sunspin you know for all
my information go to the Michael
Rosenbaum and go linktree and you can
just hit everything and just you know
you go to the inside of you online store
incredible merch Smallville I just got
new tumblers I might have to give you a
new tumbler I got white Tumblr silver
tumblers more yellow tumblers crazy
stuff man
I got a lot of tumblers from you already
I'll tumble for yeah
uh what else
if you're in the giving mode
these uh non-profits are important to me
uh foodonfoot.org tell my Essentia for
homeless that was a hope for foster
youth Ronald McDonald House
um if you don't know Ronald McDonald
House they
um pay for families to stay with their
children while they're going through
treatments like leukemia and whatever
and um it's a pretty fascinating
um non-profit and they don't get a lot
of money they need money from folks like
us you know and uh the animal rescue
mission my friend sheer asked for sure I
want to rescue an animal so many animals
need rescuing and uh
yeah will be July 15th will be in
Montreal the threesome Smallville
threesome doing a Smallville nights get
your tickets now
and all that stuff uh that's pretty much
it Ryan is everything going well in your
world yeah I was just remembering this
episode actually uh it was uh I remember
being kind of therapeutic for both of us
yeah yeah it was really fascinating yeah
I I felt the same way I um I hope that
people love it as much as I did some
sometimes you see a name you're like oh
I might not know D Wallace or Michael
Rosenbaum but you know here's the deal
listen because you're going to learn a
lot and I think it will affect you I
think you'll be glad you listened so
this is one of my favorites this is
certainly one of my favorites let's get
into the wonderful beautiful D Wallace
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience do you have things weird things
around your house no
no posters
memorabilia of what you've done oh sure
but I don't consider that weird
it's just self-indulged maybe no it's
just part of my history you know yeah
do you have a uh an ET autograph poster
from the cast on your wall somewhere
no
see I I how do you not have that I don't
know how I don't have you never thought
of that stuff when you were doing movies
no you know back in the days
back in the olden days by the way you
look unbelievable I'm not just saying it
thank you and it's not like what were
you you said to me when I saw me too I
haven't had any work done are you
serious I I am serious D he's acting now
no no I swear listen I don't wanna I
don't wanna look
I someone I know that I'm very close
with
is in there like in their late 70s and
you look like 20 years younger than them
come home with me little boy were you
I'm not that young how old do you think
I am oh God
take a while
I would have said 40. you would have
said 49. no I would have said 40ish okay
40ish is good
so whatever's good don't you think that
I've said this before but um
when you're in your 40s you're like oh I
wish I was 30 again when you're in 50s
you wish you were 40 again
and you know what we were playing this
game at dinner last night my daughter
had this thing on her phone asking
questions would you rather
stop time now
and pause go on pause
or rewind
and I said I'd pause I I've never been
happier and more fulfilled than I am
right now
ah well thanks for the interview great
uh that's
a lot to say no it's it's it's hard to
understand hard to
because I'm you know we're we're all
trying to find that we're all trying to
find that balance we're all trying to
find that that sort of
that let go this is who I am this is
what I love I'm happy I'm content I'm
whatever that's the challenge is
everybody's looking for it out there
yeah
it is and you write about these I I had
no idea you have three self-help books
you've done a TED Talk you do meditation
you do private healing sessions with d
on your website 40 years what is it D I
am d wallace.com how could you not want
to hear this voice
seriously but I'm I'm that's
a beautiful thing Ryan don't you wish
you could feel like that and maybe
that's our goal we want to just keep
working on ourselves we go to therapy
well you always work on yourself yeah
you know I mean somebody called into my
talk show once and said Dee I just want
to know when I'll be there
and my channel said there's no there to
get to
it's just a constant state of expansion
and understanding of energy
now let's go back because
you grew up in Kansas City Kansas City
Kansas Kansas City Kansas yeah uh
and when it all started there because do
you have a good childhood no yes yes
I I had a dichotomy of a childhood
um very strong mother very talented
mother she was an actress in local
theater she
she worked as a secretary but she was a
beautiful beautiful actress
directed all the religious plays at our
church I started out as baby Jesus in
the ended up as a Virgin Mary
and and then I went to Hollywood
and then you became the devil yeah and
then I did all those horror films
um and my father was
uh
a damaged creative from the war
um he was such a creative but pts after
the war my mom said he was just a
different person never the same he
worked in the Red Cross and picked up
bodies on the field and
and uh when he came back he became a
severe alcoholic
and
ended up committing suicide really
and my little brother
followed the same pattern three years
ago
oh my Lord so there was so much love and
so much
your incredible Deanna and you can do
anything and then this dichotomy of am I
okay what's going to happen I've got to
be vigilant you know was he an angry
alcoholic
at times yeah yeah at night I never saw
him hit my mother
but he verbally abused her and
berated her and yelled at her every
night of my life that I can remember and
she stayed with him yeah because do you
think she just knew where it was coming
from because I she knew he was a good
person
deep down it still affects you I could
see that yeah it does it does it's
unbelievable how our childhood no matter
what we do how much we work on it yeah
it it just there's parts of it that you
just you you have let me tell you your
little kid is running the show
so the more you can
um mine
everything that you were taught or
everything that was modeled to you in
front of you
from zero to eight years old
you will see every wall that you're
hitting as an adult
do you know the our brains
from the way we see ourselves
see ourselves in the world and how we
see the world looking at us totally in
place by eight years old
and this hits me home you have no idea
how much Ryan you know I mean it's I
always talk about the developmental
stages
from that that time period like I I
would say I would say kind of like
around it was six seven eight nine ten
yeah that that time period because what
happens is
true or false based in reality or not
you create your belief systems
and then from those belief systems
because as you believe it's delivered to
you
from those belief systems we create our
life and then we go well yeah but that's
the way life is that's the reality of my
life and it's the reality of Our Lives
because we believed those things that
were instilled in us before we had
reasoning
to work through them you're saying
in my interpretation
this is how my mind works
you're saying that as a child when I I
never felt I was loved ever I just
didn't I didn't feel that from my
parents they never told me I love you
I'm proud of you I'm you know all I just
never heard that I never
um
it was just I I didn't I never felt that
so I see in my life today it's hard to
allow people to love me because I think
no no no it's not that they don't love
it hold on okay well you can't feel
anybody's love if you don't love
yourself I guess that's it you and we're
never taught to love ourselves
none of us are we were taught that it's
braggadocious and it's you know God's
not going to love us if we're too full
of ourselves and people will judge us if
we think we're awesome
and so we're we're taught to put
ourselves down and so our little child
within us now is going I'm going to keep
you safe don't get too big I'm good
that's my job I'm going to keep you safe
and it's our job
as it's our job to be the parents of our
little child now and retrain them
into a greater truth of how awesome and
loved and loving we are yes but but it's
very difficult when the people who
created you
you don't feel like you're worthy or
you're you're good enough or yes but it
is it is a hard thing
to them anymore that's true that's true
and that's as long as you keep bringing
them into the equation you will never
move on
yeah they look according to my channel
we pick our parents
um I've heard that before
and we pick our parents to learn in most
cases what we don't want and what we
want to recreate in our lives
so they taught you
I don't feel loved
so that you could choose now in this
moment
I choose to love myself
so you know how much you love that dog
oh God when I walked in Mouse Blanche
okay so just feel that in your heart
just feel how much you love little
blends
it's funny because it makes me like oh
right when you said that it kind of
brings up like motions yeah yeah to give
that to yourself
see it really is easy but we keep making
it very I think what happens is I think
yeah I'm not a good person like I'm not
the person I want to be I sort of like
Envy certain people because I'm like
gosh I wish I was that patient and that
um
understanding or that but
um well who else is gonna create that if
you don't
but you see you have to love yourself
enough
yeah to choose to do that to be that
this is already the most effective
podcast I have 230 guests I'm already
like wow you you're speaking to a lot of
people a lot of the folks are gonna
write in and
be blown away and follow D Wallace I've
I've lived this I I know I want to get
into that because I know through my own
trauma and my own heartache and
I just realized
every moment is a choice
that's what happened then in this moment
right now how do I want to create me
did you was there a time in your life
that you remember specifically or times
where you didn't love yourself where you
didn't feel complete you didn't
understand the way yeah last week
last week
like I said it's an ongoing
creation process
this show is sponsored by better help
sometimes in life we're faced with tough
choices and the path forward isn't
always clear whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online so it's convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
betterhelp.com
inside this message is sponsored by
discover did you know you could reduce
the number of unwanted calls and emails
with online privacy protection the
latest Innovation from discover discover
will help regularly remove your personal
info like your name and address from 10
popular people search websites that
could sell your data and they'll do it
for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
so something happened on a set
uh a week or two ago and I went into an
old pattern of reaction and started
taking everything personally
and let me give you one really simple
statement whenever you're in reaction
you're out of creation
because you're out of choice
so I I took myself to my dressing room
and I looked in the mirror when I do
this I always call myself Deanna Bowers
that's my gift right
Deanna Bowers
you're totally in reaction now you're in
the toilet and there's a lot of [__] in
that toilet and you're about ready to
flush yourself down so do you want to go
down the toilet or do you want to get
out of the [__]
and choose what you want to create here
by that time I'm laughing which allows
me to
regroup
and write discharge the the reactionary
thing
and so
I got myself rebalanced and I went in
and I handled it did someone yell at you
with someone disrespectful rude well you
see no and I perceived it that way uh
uh sensitive
something well
I felt like they were not respecting
my body of work and how much I knew as
an actor
do you think ego got in the way maybe
no I I no no I I don't think it was ego
um it was
it's a pattern
that has been
repeated over and over and over in my
life of
um
people using me and disrespecting me
and so
subconsciously what happens then is
you're always on the lookout like I was
when I was a little girl is everything
okay is daddy gonna get too drunk It's
you know something gonna happen
so I'm programmed and conditioned to
look out and see those things instead of
look out and see
and it's much more on the positive side
now you know yeah but
every once in a while this happens to me
again and I get to go oh good another
opportunity to expand you know I saw
something on Instagram because they
always have these quotes and quotes
today and people think I can help you oh
this [__] and it's like oh my God and I
take screenshots and screenshots and I
never look at them again because I'm
thinking yeah I need to do that but I
don't do that but there was something
on there that said
um
if you have childhood trauma you
probably do this and it said
every situation you think of something
bad that's going to happen in that
situation
and I go
the trauma yeah I do I'm telling you the
little kids are running the show so my
channel suggests that everybody writes
down
everything that you were verbally taught
or models
in front of you around whatever wall or
subject you're you're needing to break
what if you believe by the way where's
your channel where can I find this D
wallace.com I am d wallace.com
yeah my pot my I call it it's not
podcast it's a radio show right and I'm
gonna call it I'm almost 700.
episodes please call us holy [__] and
you can ask anything you can ask about
sex you can't you know enough about sex
look at me what do you think have you
had a lot of sex in your life
I don't know you don't look like some I
mean you look like someone who's
together so I can't let maybe if I but I
don't look at you and go God she's had
sex a lot of it
well you're not looking very closely
oh my God uh but we'll get into more of
this yeah
look at the sound right did it we'll get
into more of this we'll be right back
now
um you know it's it's hard I'll just say
this
and we'll maybe we'll talk about this
more but I want to get into some other
stuff but um it is hard and I'm working
on it what's hard is okay stop right
there
you don't know what I was gonna say yeah
but I have to stop you there okay
because
all right I have to I have to explain
this to everybody everything's energy we
learned that in fifth grade right right
there is no positive or negative energy
energy is neutral energy must have a
direction in order to take manifestation
for example if you want ice
you have the intention of making ice so
you go you get the ice tray you fill it
up you put it in the refrigerator you
have a freezer freezer
excuse the [__] out of me okay yes
please so
you gave it you gave yourself a
direction and the energy followed
through you just you keep saying how
hard everything is and if you keep
saying how hard everything is that is a
direct
direction to your energy and your brain
see my work is a a combination of
spirituality and brain science
so whatever you say think or feel you're
giving your picture your brain pictures
so if you say what you don't want which
is what most people do like I don't want
to have to worry about money what does
your brain see
worrying about money which equals you
don't have enough money
so I had to stop you at heart I hear you
you know but what if you believe some of
the things that were if you believe it
it's true as you believe look if if
people can just get that they can change
their whole life for him
whatever you believe
you manifest into reality on this plane
we are the gods of us on this plane
nobody can dig a thought for us nobody
can feel a feeling for us nobody can
hold the belief for us that we don't
accept
that makes us the god of us
right so we have to be responsible for
choosing the thoughts the feelings and
the beliefs that match what we want to
create so now what was hard which is now
easy
what were you going to say nothing
I feel like you're a really smart
teacher that I like but I don't want to
oh come on no look at me I'm such a nice
bro no I like it I I just want to kind
of you are a nice broad is that a lot of
sex apparently
um look God Kansas City what
well yeah you you know just we'll get
into sex
guess where I'm from where Indiana
Southern Indiana oh I see I knew I liked
it right away right Evansville you know
Newburgh Indiana Evansville Indiana yeah
but I wouldn't move back there
that's funny you said that because I was
thinking of moving back there I couldn't
move back to Kansas City and I and I
love
Kansas and I'm so proud of all the women
who stood up in Kansas and
got the abortion thing done there but it
that's the thinking
is too limited for me now the Midwest in
the south is based in very strong
religious roots
and that's not where your head's at well
none of my work is against any religion
right it's an expansion
of the concept of what God Is Right
so I don't use the word god much I use
the word creative Force right because
people don't have any kind of negative
hooks
in the word creative force or energy but
you say God and a lot of people a lot of
children inside us
have
negative reactions to that word
all right I got you I understand you
know I do understand religion teaches us
to be small
it teaches us we don't have any power
it teaches us we have to go through
other people
to be connected to the creative force
that creates everything none of those
things are true
I mean the Big Man actually said these
Miracles and more will you do also go do
them
you know and then the popes and the
Kings got together and said well how the
hell are we going to have all the power
if we let them know they have the
creative power you're saying sort of
don't become a slave to this you have to
have to take over the power you have to
you have to we were given free will to
create ourselves on this plane um
I I like that okay I'll shut up I get up
my Baptist preacher comes in no I I I
like it it's very look and I'm telling
you okay
um
you taught High School drama I did you
have an education degree I did you never
thought you were going to be an actor
did you
always you always did but you were
always
I I've been acting since I was a little
girl
were you did you know you were good did
your mom go oh my God you have it yes
did everyone else say you have it
I don't remember but you still wanted to
get a degree
I got a degree from my mom
what do you mean my mother said okay
Dede
be an actress but just have something to
fall back on please because she had had
such a hard life right and she wanted to
know that I was safe in the world that I
could so I it just meant so much to her
my older brother uh actually my older
brother went on and got a PhD my older
brother worked its way through Seminary
shooting pictures for Playboy that kind
of sums up the dichotomy of me and my
family right there it's genius yeah oh
my god
um so you loved but you taught you
taught I taught one year how old were
the students
um
ninth and 10th grade
and how did what do you remember from
that
a lot of challenge look
back then
I would have to show my credentials to
get lunch because they thought I was one
of the kids really you know I I just
always looked really young back then and
but I
I'm a natural born teacher I love to
teach obviously I have taught all my
life I've had my own acting studio uh
out here actually one of the largest
ones for 18 years I had my own dance
studio in Kansas I taught High School
um and now I I teach life
yeah and creation and manifestation I
I just know how to
communicate on a simple way that people
can understand and relate to do you
still love acting like you did or is it
just sort of like
um paycheck it it no it depends on the
on the project and the part
I have I have a a incredible thing
coming out right now called Paul T
Goldman
it it's
the guy's name that it's about
um it's going to be out in January it's
a limited series
and I play the psychic in it and they
had no idea that I channeled when they
hired me really yeah it was it was real
so you really used it you really did it
well I mean I had
a scripted you know version of exactly
what the psychic told him which
I'm telling you you guys if you watch
this you will sit there like I did and
go oh my God oh my God this is did this
really happen I mean it's it's it's
beyond anything you can imagine and it's
real
so that's T Goldman Netflix
um uh peacock peacock
and then I am uh recurring also on um
yeah what the what's yeah of that show
that I did what is it
um
oh my god I've I've done so much work in
the last three months anyway we'll come
back you wow you do you work a lot I uh
this year
this year has been amazing but then I
have no beliefs
you see about older women actors not
being able to work well let me I don't
have any of those you have like first of
all you're not old but secondly your
mind is you're just sharp you're sharper
than my friends who are in their 40s oh
aren't you no no you're really you're is
she not really sharp yeah it's
unbelievable it's like you know things
like you you go one you have this two
you have this you start naming things
I'd be like all right five things one
[__] what was that what the [__] was
that you're like you're just on point
anyway listen
I want to go back to the when you first
you know your first big thing when you
got because you were acting you're
taking class you were going to cut you
know what's College my first big taught
for a year
well yes I've got to tell you this story
because it's so good so we got the new
the New York Times
uh in the library of the school and I'm
reading it because I know I'm kind of
hankering to go and there's this
article that
um they're looking for an unknown
to star in A Little Night Music what
became A Little Night Music
so I wrote this amazing letter and sent
this cheesy picture I have to show you
I'm on my bed
no way no [__] that's what I in back in
Kansas I thought you know provocative
um you had to show them
well they called me
and they said how Prince was the
producer Mr Prince has gotten your
letter and your picture and he'd like to
fly you to New York to audition for A
Little Night Music Now what this is how
naive I was back then because I'm from
Kansas
so I said oh my gosh that's that's
wonderful when does Mr prince need me
and they gave me the date and I went oh
my gosh that's the day I arrive I
already have a ticket I'm already going
what time does he need me five o'clock
oh I get in at two that'll you know he
would have flown me for his class put me
up the whole thing who knew I didn't you
know and they were like okay so the day
I arrived in New York City I took every
belonging I had
took it to a taxi cab said hi
could you take all this stuff to this
address please because I'm going to go
down to Rockefeller Center and audition
for help Prince and everything made it
to the address
did you give a guy a tip
well I didn't see him after he took it
sure I tipped him I knew that much the
first thing I think if you tipped him
right oh my God I give money to
everybody I mean like that too I feel
like everybody and I see somebody you
know people work hard
well and people on the street the
homeless people and people say to me oh
my God they probably have you know a
three-bedroom house and they're standing
out there
and but I always go back to Neil Donald
Walsh's conversations with God and
there's his part in it where and it made
such an impact on me where he says you
know you're walking down the street and
you see a homeless person and you go
give him something and you reach in your
pockets and you have a nickel and a five
dollar bill and you go God and nickel
then nickel's not enough
five geez I don't you know I probably
gonna need that by that time you've
passed him
and it wasn't his moment it was yours
it was your moment to go yeah I'm mad
abundant
and I'm telling you I do that all the
time and it comes back to me ten times
hardly and you know what I like about it
about giving and it comes back to haunt
me a lot of times because sometimes I
give way too much and people take
advantage that I just won't get into
that but I know that
I like to give and I like I see someone
but it's not like you know what uh I I
I'm doing a good thing and people are
looking no no it's it's
honestly I feel it I feel like I look at
the person I'm like you know what this
guy's struggling I could do something
and maybe I could get him a cup of
coffee I'd give him 20 bucks that's
right how's your day whatever it is I I
do that I do that with people like the
counter person at Burger King yeah hey
they're like how's it going it's going
I'm like yeah blah blah blah you know
how to stop talking to him I go hey you
know it's almost the weekend and you
know and I just try to be whatever and
try to give them a little something
whatever yeah I just never give at the
expense of yourself right I I want
people to hear that because a lot of us
are brought up
to
think that we're better people if we
give ourselves up for other people
but what happens then is
you take the responsibility from that
person of them creating themselves
if you enable them too much right so
that actually dis empowers them what do
you think of when she says that yes this
is the best podcast
I think I think of my mother I think of
like I enable her and I give and I give
and she goes every text is like oh how
would you decide about that job what are
you trying to get me in like ah but I
miss you so much I gotta see you and
blah blah oh my God I can't afford this
thing I don't know what I'm gonna do
it's always manipulated it's always yeah
it's always a passive aggress it's just
it's been like that my whole life
especially since my parents got divorced
that has been like I I feel like I say
this with love
who's allowing that me I know that's it
my business manager says it didn't
change it Michael I'm not doing this
anymore it's like either do it or you
don't
oh I like your business man yeah do it
or you don't I don't want to hear it you
know
do it or you don't well but he's right
he can't make that decision for you yeah
see you have to know
that you can love her
and do love her without doing that we're
going to get into this I am going to get
into it well I like I want to I want I
want us to be friends God's sakes you're
just like do you you should be a
therapist
yeah like I could buy a session from you
for an hour
well I do half hour sessions believe me
that's all you need and wait so you'll
talk to me for half an hour first
yeah he's doing it for free actually
give you a session
really I'll just gift you one
because you know I'll be hooked it'll it
all comes back to me I just want you to
be able to take this into your life and
take it out into you to your listeners
everybody everybody wants to be free yes
and we're the only ones that can free
ourselves
let's go back to him that's the good
news and the bad news you give the taxi
guy okay okay
so I got down to the last five girls in
the dancing and the acting and they say
all right we Mr Prince would like to
hear you sing and I
oh I didn't know what he had to sing
his secretary looked up at me and she
says well dear it is a musical
sweetheart sing happy birthday
and a company and it says what key and I
went any somewhere in the middle that's
what I would have said
so the first day uh I auditioned for how
Prince and got down to the wire didn't
get it but by the time I left
because there were so many great you
know performers there I knew where to go
to study who to study singing with you
know I learned a lot I got all that down
boy you know and I'm telling you my
naivete
has just taken me through my career I'm
a huge believer in naivetech
wholeheartedly yeah I think it's the
reason like I I became successful too
because they were like oh my God you
know how the odds are becoming an actual
like not for me I'm I'm different I'm I
mean I people wouldn't believe it I
remember this girl in college uh uh
Alexis Combs loved her she was awesome
we're sitting on the steps is right
after I did this play it's my senior
year and I go Alexis
I don't want you to forget this moment
I'm not bullshitting you I'm going to
New York and I'm going to become famous
remember this moment because I swear
it's going to happen it's there's no
doubt in my mind it is going to happen
it was just like you said an energy it
was like naivete it was all this [__]
and I and I think a lot of that was sort
of like yeah I'll go in for that
tomorrow sure now I think overthink
everything now I'm like I need four days
to prepare for that okay okay but you
so go back to the zero point of when you
knew
I I I still know it's just yeah you do
you do still but you have to tell
yourself you know
yeah you know otherwise you don't know I
know
um yeah you talk about this ad nauseam
but if I don't bring it up some of these
ideas people will well people will just
be like well first of all we're getting
the good things when you got E.T well
first you got the howling
well first I got a religious film what
was that uh all the king's horses that I
did with Grant good eve and then I went
right into The Hills Have Eyes again the
dichotomy of me so darn The Hills Have
Eyes that was probably like were you was
that like at that point like the hardest
thing you've ever done it's the only
thing I'd ever done really come on it
was my first gig were you nervous
somebody asked me he said were you
worried about how dark it was were you
worried about what it would do to your
character dude it was my first like
leading role I'm going [__] I got a card
you know let's go yeah I guess we are
obviously yeah okay obviously Spielberg
saw that and was like and then
um
um I did the howling and
10 with Blake Edwards was in Dudley
Moore yeah by the way Dudley Moore is
one of my favorite actors of all time
one of my favorites tell me just tell me
a story you haven't told that you're a
member of Dudley's anything small big
whatever
definitely and I danced on many table
tops in Mexico
and I would uh go out with the crew and
hang out with the crew and he was just
so giving as an actor and so lovely as a
person I just I just loved him and so
there was a scene
which you'll probably remember if you
remember the movie 10. Bo Derek and
um Dudley is playing the piano oh yes
and uh so we did the scene and
Blake everybody's breaking down we're
moving on to the next thing and Dudley
starts to play and D
is sitting there so moved by his playing
that tears came to my eyes and Blake
stopped and he said everybody come back
bring everything back we're gonna get a
close-up of Dee listening to Dudley play
and it's this huge
and you know that happens to me on every
set with great directors they see
something happening on E.T in the dinner
table scene
um is that the yelling thing we snapped
or no that was the Laughing thing
oh it's winning to the big dinner table
scene where
um we are talking about maybe he just
imagined it right and then it gets into
well why don't you call your father I
can't he's in Mexico with Sally right
when he said that as Mary
I took such a hit
and the tears I could feel the tears
coming up and I literally had the
thought as Mary
I can't let the kids see me cry so I got
up from the table and left which was not
in the script
and Steven yells cut and he comes over
and goes D why did you get up and leave
that's that's not in the script and I
explained to him what happened and he
looked at me
he said everybody come in you got a half
an hour I need you to build me a wall
with a running kitchen sink right there
so he could take me over to the sink and
then bring me back into that big
close-up where I says he hates Mexico
and it all just but that's a good
director they see
they see the moments and you have to you
remember that you know if you don't you
have to watch it I I haven't seen the
movie in many years and I immediately
remember that moment it almost makes me
emotional because I remember that moment
I remember like you're like it's like
trying yeah oh my gosh yeah and
every every every major I mean it
happened with Peter Jackson all the
times yeah oh man what a what a lovely
man Peter Jackson is man and so talented
yes
um Michael J fox I mean it would happen
with Joe Dante and Louis Teague all the
time I remember in Cujo do you remember
that I just saw it and I didn't know I
was yes see it starts saying I want my
daddy and I said all right I'm guessing
your father right and then you start
crying you kind of go I'm dancing your
father like you were almost you're
emotional like but you couldn't take it
anymore it was awesome it came to me the
next day and said D we need you to look
at the dailies from yesterday it's such
a powerful scene but we think we might
cut it because we're afraid people won't
like you
they didn't so I never watched dailies
but I said okay
and I went to Dan Blatt our beloved
producer and I said Dan if you got that
senior crazy there's not a parent in the
world that hasn't felt that moment
and they kept it in and it was the most
well reviewed scene in the movie
that movie you know you know what's
funny I swear to God I wouldn't I
wouldn't bring it up if I didn't
if I didn't mean it um I have horror
movie Nights every Tuesday night with my
friends it's the guys and we watch
horror movies and I go oh you've seen a
lot of me oh yeah oh yeah I go have you
guys ever seen Cujo and they're like no
I'm like are you [__] [__] are you
[__] kidding me you've never seen
Cujo and they go yeah all right let's
watch I go all right cool look I
remember this movie being intense and I
loved it it may not hold up I don't know
but let's watch it
and everybody unanimous it was
boy did it hold up yeah and it was you
know why it was because of the acting
you that little Danny oh my God
unbelievable
thank God I got that kid for that role
because it was just him and me and him
and me I couldn't believe he was the
things that he was doing like almost
dead well and what was funny was because
I'm you know it's why I play mothers I
get very motherly with all these kids
and I said okay Danny now
tomorrow we're gonna do the scene where
you have to do the seizure
so do you want to rehearse it are you
afraid of any he says oh that happened
to me when I was little you want to see
and he goes right into it and I went I
so do not have to worry about this
freaking kid at all oh really yeah he he
was
just an old soul how much did you hate
being in that car I if I never see
another Pinto again in my life it will
be too soon how how many days do you
think you filmed oh we were we were in
the pinto half of half of the shooting
once you hit the halfway point the rest
of it in the pinto yeah and a lot of
people think you know we were dying in
the heat we were actually really really
cold because it was in Northern
California in November and December
my God and they used like how many
they use the mechanical dog they used a
bunch of different dogs okay I read
stuff but I don't know if it's true okay
yeah there were 13 dogs that played Cujo
all trained to go after toys Saint
Bernards
because
you could you can't overwork a dog you
can overwork an actor
and and they treated me for exhaustion
for three weeks after that film but
there were 13 dogs that played Cujo
uh Gary Morgan was our wonderful
stuntman and he didn't do that much in
in the movie the real dogs did almost
every shot you know what's crazy about
that movie as much as you care for you
guys
you really feel bad for the dog yeah
like that dog is a mess
all the [__] that they put on it and you
just like especially if you're a dog
lover you saw these you're like oh my
God yeah but Cujo dies you're like it
wasn't crucial's fault he had he had he
had rabies and it was like yeah his mine
was gone and that's why we had to
we had to really create so much Terror
and and horrible things that Cujo had
done
in order to get to the that last scene
where he's coming through the door
through the broken glass you know so the
audience goes yeah shoot him because
Danny's gonna die you have to do that
right that's amazing it's amazing how
that moment you have to have it you know
in the book Danny dies
and Stephen oh yeah yeah I knew that
yeah Stephen King
um called Dan Blatt and said thank God
you didn't kill the kid at the end you
couldn't do that he never got more hate
mail in his life than when he killed
Danny at the end of Kuja really that's
what he's that's what I was told did you
like Stephen King I did I only met him
one day he he came down to the set at
the beginning of shooting very
how would I describes what I remember as
Stephen King is a gentleman a gentleman
a very yeah soft-spoken
gentlemen did he look like someone who
look you gotta have demons to write [__]
that he writes no you don't think so no
I do
oh I think he he's creative but why is
it always so dark there's something
don't you think there's something going
on if 95 of what you're right is really
really dark [__]
what's what's I I have mixed
I have
I have mixed emotions about that makes
thinking about that right one of my
clients called and said Dee I'm taking
this out of class and the teacher said
that anybody that is involved in horror
films in in any way is damaging their
energy and and their psychic I said well
I'm telling you that's [__]
because would you tell a little
five-year-old girl who's playing a witch
in a play oh she's gonna damage her
psyche or or the kid that says I'm gonna
be the alligator and Peter Pan and come
get everybody that he's it's just
[__] we're doing what we love that's
fantasy we are doing what we love that
makes us happy I'm glad you said that
because look at the movies around you
Evil Dead Lost Boys Jaws uh you know the
thing um Nightmare on Elm Street Dracula
Return of the Living Dead Friday the
13th I love horror movies and I start to
think is there something wrong with me I
don't think you should Google I want
everybody my mom made me watch horror
movies with her from the time I was
eight just so go ahead oh
positive effects of horror films
you will be stand write that downside
remember it it does positive things for
your brain for your nervous system
it helps you learn how to deal with
trauma
so that's why every Disney film has a
really scary character in it
you know when we would watch
um The Little Mermaid my daughter would
go Mommy lady get big part lady get big
part where Ursula gets big and you know
she wanted to see that over and over
again so she could sit there in a in a
safe place like we do when we go to a
theater
and learn how to handle her fears
I mean seriously is there anything that
you've seen in the theater that's worse
than what's going on in our world
no yeah that's my case uh tell me about
I know it's probably not easy because I
know you're an emotional person like I
am oh dear but you're just like I know
you met
your your husband Christopher Stone on
chips you met him on chips
we had both worked for the direct this
director and he called us and said oh my
God you guys I have this will you please
come in and help me so we both did
and Christopher was very established is
he Charming
no okay he was gorgeous yeah but he he
spent the whole week trying to direct me
oh you didn't like that and so the last
day we had to ride back together
in the same car and he said so you know
what some of your latest stuff and I
said well I just had this amazing
episode on Lou Grant and he went
oh my God that's you
you played the hooker
and I said yeah did you see it he said
not only did I see it I ran into my wife
at the time he was getting divorced and
and I said you've got to come look this
this girl's gonna be a big star he said
oh my God that's you
I literally changed before his very eyes
I'm not kidding from this girl who I
better give her some direction to holy
[__] I'm working with that guy that
girlfriend the hooker episode of Blue
Grant so that was back in the days when
we all had
what did we call them the pagers oh yeah
yeah right and you went through
answering Services put who was they were
never supposed to give out your personal
information remember right well
Christopher could get gold out of a
monkey's butt and so by the time I got
home
there were two dozen roses
sitting at my front door
he had not only gotten my address from
them
he had gotten my phone number and so
about a half hour I got home he called
me and he said
did you get the flowers I said yes that
was very sweet of you thank you he said
well I'd like to take you to dinner
okay um
can you go to dinner Friday night and I
said I'm sorry I already have plans I
said but I could go Saturday night and
he said oh well Saturday night's my
standing thing with uh with all my guys
I play poker and I might he said what
about Sunday and he said I'm sorry I
have plans on Sunday but you know call
me in a couple of weeks he said no
Saturday night I'll pick you up at seven
and he did not let me out of his sight
or his life
after that
you fell deep in the love oh my God like
like that and it just it never did you
have any rough times I'm sure of course
everybody has a rough time but you guys
were in love until the end right until
the end yeah and that probably hit you
like a [__] brick yeah I mean
suddenly when he had I was doing The
Frighteners
when he had the heart attack and so I
flew back
they did his angioplasty he came through
it he was going home the next day he
said honey you've got to fly back
they're holding filming for you
I'm fine so I did four days later he
Glock got up a blood clot hit its heart
and and he died and my little girl found
him
Gabrielle found him
so I flew back to do his service
and then I picked up my kid and my nanny
and flew I was back you know it's
halfway across the world
Australia or New Zealand oh yeah and I
was back and forth four times in two and
a half weeks I didn't know whether I was
coming or going how did how did you even
I don't know I I would have probably I
mean you think I don't know what I've
done you don't know until you're next
Peter said D we never expected you they
had figured out how to shoot around me
and shoot from my back and would you
break down out of the blue
constantly was a constant like you
couldn't handle your emotions you know
yeah I I know no I
I was taught by my mother
watching how she handled all the stuff
of my father
you know I mean he he tried to commit
himself twice so I tried to kill himself
twice and finally succeeded behind a bar
when I was a
senior in high school
and
she was so strong
and she just taught me
you handle it you handle what you handle
and you get through what you have to get
through
so I got back there
and
I I went to the set I had to shoot the
scene
where
uh Michael J fox
or I
drop dead and we go Through the Wormhole
yep
and I watched Michael
I watched Michael and before he hit the
floor he be he turned into Chris
wow and
afterwards
the producer came to me and she said Dee
I want you to go see
my doctor so that she can make sure
you know that you're
emotionally okay
and I walked in and this lady looked at
me and she said oh my God
you know they're very into alternative
medicine and
she said you have no life force
at all I can't even work on you
until I work on your life force
and this is
I had already been kind of veering into
The Healing Arts
but this she laid me down on a table and
she put gemstones on all my chakras
and I thought well that's pretty weird I
know yeah
I'm telling you in a half an hour I felt
like I was Reborn
and then she gave me some homeopathic
medicine and she there was somebody on
the set that was supposed to give me
three every three hours or whatever it
was
and everybody you know
just rallied around me and got me
through that took care of my daughter
she was only seven years old and
I remember
um she was there when I was practicing
flying in the you know in the harness
and she said oh Mommy I want to fly like
Peter Pan and they made her a little
harness so she could go
Michael would play Foursquare with her
oh my and and so at the end of the
brighteners
because they just you know this was for
business class flights back and forth
and two and a half weeks
and they said don't worry D we'll take
care of it you can settle up at the end
of the movie well it would have been
more
I think than my whole salary and I went
in
to pay it off and
oh sorry no the bookkeeper looked at me
and she said this is Peter's gift to you
he's just gonna absorb all of this and
that's the kind of guy
Peter Jackson are you kidding me yeah
holy crap
that's beautiful yeah it really is
beautiful
sorry no no I love your emotion I love
your vulnerability it just tells me
everything about you you know that
you're just you're human you really show
your emotions and you you've lived your
life you've lived you've gone through
the lowest of lows and look at you
and this is what well again
those were those moments what am I going
to do with this moment
I can stay a victim
or I can be victorious over my own life
I choose B
I mean wow
you're getting a big hug for me after
this I hope so I mean it's gonna be okay
because I'm coming on for you so I'm
telling you right now holy crap let's
get into sex before you leave
we're almost done I mean we're almost
done I mean this is Segway I mean I I
could I honestly to God I
I could talk to you I feel like I could
talk to you forever like this is it's
weird because I'm like well I've written
it all down
born giving birth to a new you it's
literally the formula for manifesting
everything in your life
and I brought you one you did yeah it's
in my purse it is the book is called
Born it is a book about directing energy
knowing neutrality self-actualization
knowing you are the power claiming your
desires and easy creation yeah
look God created the world in seven days
how hard could it be guys
seriously you know
this is what I want
I know I created I match it with love
I ask the universe to partner with me
it's really pretty simple you know it's
funny what I just thought of what I have
your assistance email and I'm like
I have I want a D's email her really you
can have it I won't be at imdwallis.com
everybody can have it
really so anybody could email you yeah
so you go through thousands of emails
yeah
she's D I told you this story before we
again busy girl
healing acting healing yeah I think well
let's get real funny uh well sex who's
the most famous person you had sex with
did you have sex with Dudley Moore oh
God no okay no okay all right uh
probably Christopher really
I'm trying it oh
I just thought of somebody I don't want
to say
um it was when I first got it is this a
personal live
uh I no I don't think so okay well who
cares no I can't I can't is it a big
star
he is pretty big star yeah but
Christopher was it from one of the
movies you worked on no damn it now like
now it kind of illuminates certain
things no no you would never guess in a
million years all right uh uh you tell
me after I will never mention it I want
it's not not here I I'm not never mind
uh this is called [__] talking with D
Wallace it's rapid fire you answer fast
oh I hate this you have to do it these
are my top tier patrons go to
patreon.com inside of you they give to
the podcast they keep it going Dana asks
with being an OG on the horror scene do
you get creeped out over anything
besides my fake spider in the spider in
the bathroom oh and spiders and snakes
and guns I hate guns and I have to
[__] use one in every movie I do
I hate guns my dad killed himself with a
gun my brother killed himself with a gun
I don't see any use for guns in this
world
amen I'm with you I'm with you
um
by the way the spider quickly you worked
with the spiders on what The Hills Have
Eyes big freaking tarantula and they
said that they don't they don't buy
these oh yeah there's no they're not
dangerous they can't hurt you and then
afterwards they said well actually they
can deep but we milked it first
they milk the spider yeah they poisonous
yeah
great huh great thanks Sophie M what was
the casting process for et like
actually they just offered me E.T I had
auditioned for Stephen for used cars oh
I love used cars and I didn't
fortunately I know but I loved it
you see this car right here the price is
2 400.
too [__] high
slams it with a with a sledgehammer and
dude it was uh what's his name uh right
there Kurt Russell yeah oh God that
movie's hilarious I was destined to do
E.T did they pay you well in E.T yes
because I yelled out really long time
are you serious yes well it's
negotiation yes you know that's the way
it goes how much money do you think
you've made in residuals on ET from 1982
no no not enough
do you still get him you still get them
yes and I feel blessed every single time
a check comes in
you still talk to any of the cast
members oh gosh the boys and I are on
tour all the time are you serious we go
to the cons all the time do you think
Henry would do this I'm friends with
Mike Flanagan who's friends with him
who's he's been in a lot of his projects
I should talk to Mike or you yeah she's
a good guy talk to mine oh Henry Henry's
fabulous he's wonderful it says Robert
oh and so you know we did Drew an hour
show with Drew this year yeah I saw that
that was amazing that was great they she
did a really wonderful job with that
show I thought mother who's made you
laugh who was the funniest person you've
ever worked with that you you always
were like about to laugh Dom DeLuise oh
yeah my God and it was I had all these
serious scenes what movie oh it was a
movie of the week okay called Happy
and and so I would get ready to do all
these serious things and and he'd look
at me and go
[Music]
and he would just go off
hysterically I mean Dudley was pretty
funny too but Tom
this is the whole time deadly more
though to me you know that movie Arthur
have you ever seen it Ryan please watch
it oh my God there's a scene there's a
scene when he brings up he brings a
prostitute to this fancy restaurant and
he sees his aunt and his uncle and he
goes oh Uncle Harry and through whatever
that's pretty good this is um princess
Gloria and she's a PR and he goes she
goes princess
yes
she comes from a very small country in
the West Indies it's so small they
recently had the whole country commented
I'm talking small and it's like it goes
on because it's so small a taxi camera
as just five minutes long across the
country it's so small he has Arthur we
realize it's small
he was I just spent the whole time
trying to keep up with deadly oh you're
a prostitute if I was doing so good with
you I love that I love that [__] okay
um Kelly yes any funny stories about
working with Spielberg you can share
with us
funny stories was he a serious guy did
he laugh a lot oh no he's like very
childlike on this set especially with
the kids I mean he he just loves what he
does you know he would
shoot pinball with the kids and and all
that stuff but I I wouldn't describe
Steven it's funny
I would describe him as
childlike genius Wonder
did he come up with stuff on sets or
like little things that you go holy [__]
this guy's freaking unreal like I'll
just say you know try doing this way he
literally gave me about three directions
you went on your own those laughs with
you when you start laughing and you're
like that until that was all
that penis breath that was all just what
happened
I'm not kidding around I was in love
with you when I was young like I was in
love with you I'm not well no they're
not lying you gotta go back and watch it
you're so Charming it was the Halloween
dress you're the mom everybody wanted
yeah I was a MILF oh my God you're a
MILF I was now you're a gilf
Raj is there
and I unfortunately know what that means
do you do yes uh Raj is there a moment
that stands out where you felt you had
made it as an actor yes and you know
you're going to be surprised but I
I believe it was after I saw the
screening
of the hooker in Lou Grant
and I looked I looked at that and I went
yeah I've got it
you knew yeah I I knew
as far as making it
as far as people knowing my name
probably 10.
unbelievable do you like watching
yourself
um
I don't not like watching myself I don't
watch myself a lot
um I like watching myself with with my
kid you know and letting her see some of
the and now uh my my granddaughter
um showing her you know some of the old
older things that I did and some of my
series stuff my my daughter really never
saw so I really enjoy that but I I have
to tell you
you know Christopher would look at stuff
he did and go okay I won't do that again
yeah that was pretty good
I I can't do that I I just watch and I
I am proud to say
that when I watch me I always think I'm
very truthful
and that's the end all and be all for me
ah this has been an absolute Joy an
absolute like on it has oh my god did
you really like this I've had so much
fun uh you know what I'm not kidding ah
like I doubt I want you back we never
got to sick so
are you are you a very sexual person
very very like you love having sex I
love having sex even like I'm not saying
you're all but even at 73 years old when
people think oh they stop when they're
70s they was 80s they stopped having sex
people don't have sex they just live
together so that's [__] right in my
house it is
really hey you created the way you want
it dude do you have to have sex every
week no every couple weeks that's nice
yeah do you always are you someone who
initiates sometimes
sure
doesn't it turn you on when your partner
initiates
I would say that's true if I want to
create something I create it
I don't wait for somebody else to create
it I love that when you when after
Christopher passed how long did it take
before you started dating a long time a
long time yeah like you just couldn't do
it
I didn't want to do it
you know I wanted to be with my little
girl and help her get through that and
then one day she looked at me and she
said Mommy
I need it Daddy
oh my gosh she just said that yeah
and I said
okay I'll get on that
how old was she
she was
probably nine
and you started dating immediately
yeah well I mean yeah
and I married a wonderful wonderful man
skip bellier
who uh we were married for 13 years and
he was an amazing stepfather for her and
he passed no he's not passed he's not
you just we just went our separate ways
but still talk we're very good friends
yeah it's beautiful and he was a
beautiful
stepfather
and Gabby you know how she handled it
she would say she would never say daddy
she would say Daddy Chris or daddy skip
say remember when Daddy Chris with blah
blah blah and I talked to Daddy skip
today and you know oh wow you know it's
obvious that Chris was your true love in
your life that's I I just it's apparents
was my soulmate he was your soulmate
yeah
and you were married for 20 years 18
years before he passed yeah
well but he's with me yeah he's probably
laughing over there in the corner now he
had such a
you could tell what a character he was
he could be intense he could be this he
could be that oh yeah it's so funny
because he always played the bad guys
and he wasn't like the softest teddy
bear you could ever meet this big Burly
Marie yeah you know I love it teddy bear
the book is born uh you have to get her
book on on directing energy and so many
other things you can go to uh D
wallace.com or Amazon or Amazon uh you
could hear meditations you could book
her for a half an hour I am doing it uh
I am blown away by this interview I hope
you are uh let me know what you think
let her know what you think what's your
Instagram
it's not Deez Nuts
God
you had your hand under that you guys
don't know he opened with that too but
we're joking around
well I love you I love you I mean we
have some I mean oh God you're just a
you're just a tree all right we'll close
it on that thank you this is probably
the longest podcast I've done love
yourself guys
that's my lap my final words what do I
say love yourself love yourself and love
yourself more you know what's funny
that's what I say at the ever my last
words really free podcast they say love
yourself
oh wait do I do that be good to yourself
be good to yourself be good to yourself
well I'll add you can't be good to
yourself if you don't love yourself
that's right baby
what was that one thing everyone all
right I love you I love you too thanks
for uh allowing me to be inside of you
today you bet okay
awesome you know what's funny is I love
that I said Deez Nuts how good has
anybody ever say that to you and she
went with it she went with it she's game
she's gay man what a joy she is she's
just so much fun I want to hang out with
her yeah I text her so she get lunch she
didn't respond oh well she doesn't want
to hang out with you then maybe not
people say they want to hang up with me
on the podcast they have so much fun
they leave and they just forget this
older woman does not want to hang out
with you what a bummer
now she's gonna call
Michael that's not true it's true t
um thanks for listening uh if you didn't
listen all the stuff in the beginning
you might want to rewind and listen to
the intro there's a lot of great
information there on the podcast and the
band and all that stuff if you want to
zoom me Zoom me and Welling
patreon.com inside of you to become a
patron uh we need you we love you and
here are the top tier patrons Nancy D
Leah K it's Leah S I don't know why he
puts Leah K little Lisa you Kiko Jill e
Brian H Nico paid Robert Bay
Jason w
Sophie M Raj C Joshua D what accent is
that
I don't know
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B now
I'm jumping to the Dave Dave Hall
Mikey Eldon Supremo 99 more Santiago M
Chad W Liam P my uh p p p p p p p p
Atty s the Maya P thanks for the Red
Bulls in I believe Toronto you saved me
I was I was tired Maddie asked Belinda
and Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray H tab of
the T Tom and Talia and Betsy D Angel
and Rhiannon and C Cory K devnex and
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D of War
Joanne Eugene and Leah Corey Heather L
Jake B Angela F Mill s Carolyn R
Christine s Eric h
Shane R Andrew M what happened to
zaroichi remember zoduichi maybe maybe
they're just in Smallville now maybe
I don't know they left me I don't know I
don't know Tim L Oracle Amanda R gen B
Kevin e Stephanie K Jarrell jam and Jay
Leanne J Luna R Mike app Stone H Brian L
Aaron R Kendall L Meredith I Kara C
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol hi Marisol p
and Andrew M and Estevan G and Kaylee J
Brian a Ashley F Marion Louise L Romeo
the band Veronica Q Frank B Genty Nikki
L couldn't do it without you thanks for
being a patron thanks for tuning in to
the podcast and by the way the patron
thing is is really cool because not only
to get shout outs and boxes and little
notes sent from me we do YouTube lives
just for the patrons we do I do bonus
episodes sometimes I'll do a zoom with
the top tiers
um sometimes we meet up uh in cities at
different cons which I'm trying to work
out now uh it's it's it's cool I I hope
you join and help the podcast and uh
thank you for listening from Michael
Roosevelt I'm here in the Hollywood
Hills of California I'm in Hollywood
here as well yes he is let's ride the
Tails everybody and we waved the camera
thanks guys be good to yourself and I'll
see you next week
foreign